Let's get started.
Uh so this lecture we're going to be
talking about uh JAX,
which is
uh a Python library.
Hands up, who's heard of JAX?
Okay, most of you. Hands up, who's
actually actively used JAX?
One person. Yeah, okay.
Good. So So it's something you've
definitely heard about, I'm sure. Um
and it's a library that I'm using a lot
now in my research and I think a lot of
people who are carrying out scientific
machine learning are using libraries
like JAX
uh to carry out their experiments. And
so
the purpose of of this lecture is to
give you a high-level overview of what
the library is and and why it's useful
for all the kind of techniques that
we've been studying so far. So,
you know, coding up and training things
like neural operators, physical formal
networks, hybrid workflows, these sort
of things.
Um
So we'll hopefully spend the first half
of this lecture talking about JAX and
then I'll try to move on to symbolic
regression. We're a little bit behind,
so
um
we I won't finish symbolic regression
this lecture. We'll move on and cover it
on Friday as well. Um
Okay.
So
I'm going to be explaining to you what
JAX is. I'm going to be talking about
the core kind of functionality of JAX
and how it's maybe a little different to
other
uh deep learning or auto differentiation
libraries like PyTorch and TensorFlow.
Um I'll do some live coding and then
I'll also talk a bit about how we can
use JAX for for SciML.
So you should, by the end of the
lecture, hopefully have a basic
familiarity with JAX,
um understand what this core idea of JAX
is, which is single function
transformation. I'll tell you what that
is in much more detail.
And then be aware of how you can use JAX
to to work on these scientific machine
learning algorithms and research
questions.
So what is JAX? I already said JAX is a
Python library
and
it simply does these two things. Uh
one is accelerated array computation.
So this is doing JAX is extremely fast
uh uh
uh array computation. So basic kind of
linear algebra computations.
And it does it is able it allows you to
do that not on the CPU, but also on the
GPU and and
fully exploit the parallelism of like
our modern GPU devices.
It also has this really amazing feature,
which is program transformation and this
is kind of the heart of JAX and how JAX
is JAX is designed. So we'll we'll talk
about why this is such a powerful idea
uh coming up.
Um but these two things combined
together makes it very easy and very
powerful
uh to to design kind of these high
high-performing, highly scalable
uh scientific machine learning
algorithms. Or you can just um ML um
algorithms or even just scientific
computing. It doesn't have to be both at
the same time.
So just to give you some motivation why
why JAX is interesting and why a lot of
people using it now. Um JAX has been
used to build some of the biggest
machine learning models. So it was it's
developed by uh Google
and so a lot of the kind of uh Google's
biggest products and research are built
in JAX.
So I I imagine everyone's heard of
Gemini. This is Google's uh recent LLM
model, large language model. So this
model was trained in JAX and used all of
JAX's kind of functionality to
train that model across thousands of
GPUs and and really scale the training.
Um also AlphaGo. So this is again
DeepMind's algorithm that was able to
play chess and go and other other games
uh extremely well and and exceed human
performance. This was a a massive kind
of breakthrough um a few years ago.
So the underlying algorithm behind this
is a Monte Carlo tree search algorithm,
which has some kind of learnable
components to it. And again, this kind
of kind of advanced kind of uh search
algorithm was written is written in JAX
and and there's a whole implementation
that you can look at on GitHub for it.
JAX has also been used a lot in uh
scientific computing today. Um so here's
just three examples of kind of
state-of-the-art libraries. So we have
another library from Google, which is
AlphaFold. So
everyone's I imagine has heard of this.
This is the model that is able to carry
out accurate 3D uh prediction of the
structure of proteins.
Um there's also Brax, which is a library
which is able to do kind of robotic
like rigid body simulations
for reinforcement learning
typically.
Um so this is being heavily developed
and contributed to.
And then there's a lot of papers that
are coming out using JAX to to do, you
know, scalable scientific computing. So
this is a a simulation of the ocean
surface velocity simulated um
in 24 hours across 16 A100 GPUs. So this
is like state-of-the-art GPUs simulation
of of climate dynamics.
And again, this paper used JAX to
implement this model.
Okay, so that's kind of a a sale I guess
it's a sales pitch for why JAX is useful
or is being used right now. So
uh
what I want to do is get into the the
library in a bit more detail and and
tell you why
um people are using this to do
scientific machine learning tasks.
So first I'm just going to talk about
the accelerated array computation. So
this is something that uh you know,
other deep learning libraries, PyTorch,
TensorFlow also do very well.
Um but JAX is just the same, so
uh what's nice about JAX is that it uh
you can in somehow somehow think of it
as just NumPy on the CPU and GPU.
So one of the core libraries inside JAX
or one of the core modules inside JAX is
is jax.numpy and you could just think of
this as basically a a JAX version of
NumPy and the the kind of syntax uh is
both is is exactly the same or tries to
be exactly the same.
Um so to be able to port NumPy to the
GPU or to basically to run these fast
like linear algebra computations of of
arrays, uh
um JAX uses this thing called XLA, which
is accelerated linear algebra.
Uh so this is uh this is a
software that compiles the code, the JAX
code, and allows it to run very fast on
whichever device you're using, whether
it's a CPU or or GPU.
Um I'm not going to get into the details
of of how XLA works. You can just think
of this as the kind of uh
core engine that makes makes makes stuff
fast in JAX.
Um
And the program transformation. So what
is brilliant about JAX is that it allows
you to kind of
uh also carry out auto diff and also
automatically parallelize your code and
and and compile your code as well. And
all of these things can be thought of as
a as a transformation of functions.
Um
and this is what really allows what
makes JAX very powerful for our kind of
scientific computing um
methods.
So I'll go through each of these in turn
uh later.
So let's just talk about the accelerated
array computation to start with.
So yeah, JAX is simply or can be simply
thought of as NumPy on the GPU.
So on the left, this is some very
standard NumPy code. I'm just defining
it a matrix and then doing a matrix
multiplication
and printing the output.
And uh
hopefully everyone's very familiar with
NumPy and how how it works and and you
can just see when we import jax.numpy
the
the semantics syntax is exactly the
same. So we define an array in the same
way. We can use the same kind of matrix
multiplication operators and we get
obviously the same result.
Okay, so
uh all the other functionality in NumPy
like numpy.sum, numpy.arange, all this
stuff is also in jax.numpy
and defined defined the same.
So
what's interesting though is that the
the JAX code will run on a GPU if your
system has a GPU uh device.
This is this is what makes JAX different
to NumPy because NumPy is just just
defined for the CPU and highly optimized
for CPU uh
uh devices.
And so what's great is that if this is a
really large matrix matrix multiply, for
example. So if I do a a matrix matrix
multiply in NumPy, so this is 10,000 by
10,000 matrix multiply.
NumPy that takes about 7 seconds just to
do the to do the matrix multiply um
on my uh MacBook computer here.
If I do the same thing on a uh
Nvidia GPU using the JAX code, it's 126
times faster
just to do that uh single matrix
multiply.
So can anyone tell me why running a
matrix multiply on a GPU is is faster
than a CPU?
Well.
It will do all the row and column
products
Yeah.
Yeah, cuz you can do all the row and
column products at the same time. So why
exactly? What is it about a GPU that
lets you kind of parallelize?
That's how GPUs are built, yeah. Anyone
know?
Who knows what the architecture of the
GPU looks like or how does it look
different to a CPU?
Go on. It has hundreds of little cores.
Yeah.
Yeah, so CPUs So, here we go.
Uh so, I just asked this question. So,
CPUs and GPUs, this is a very high-level
sketch of what uh the actual device
looks like, the hardware looks like.
And what CP You can think of CPUs as
just consisting of a small number of
cores.
You know, a laptop might have 16 cores
or 32 cores, say.
Uh
and these cores are designed to be
incredibly fast and really, really good
at serial computation.
So, that's sequential computation.
That's computation that depends on its
previous inputs.
And and these types of computations are
uh the ones that we usually need when
we're running like an operating
operating system on a computer.
We do lots of tasks in sequence.
And that's what they're designed for,
and they have very low latency, and
they're they're really good at these
tasks.
GPU, on the other hand, you can think of
it as having
thousands and thousands of cores uh
instead of just a few like 10 or
something or 16.
And they are designed for running
uh computations that are highly
parallel. So, you know, the same
computation that that can be done on
across all the cores, and then that that
computation can be collected and and uh
uh output by the GPU.
So, they're designed for parallel
processing, and they're designed for
high throughput computations and and,
you know, originally Nvidia uh GPUs or
Nvidia's a company was like focused on
uh game game development and and the
kind of
computations that you need to to render
games. But, it just so happens that GPUs
and these kind of parallel uh
computation is exactly what we need when
we're doing kind of linear algebra
computations.
Yeah.
Uh what do you mean by overhead?
I actually think the communication's
faster because the cores are you know,
on this on the device.
So, the readout is incredibly incredibly
quick.
I think when you have multiple CPUs, it
can if they're on, you know, on
different nodes, then it can take much
longer to communicate between them.
Um
I mean, it's worth testing. If you if
you But, I I would imagine a GPU would
be a multi-threaded CPU uh for matrix
matrix multiply.
Given how optimized these these devices
have become in in in recent years as
well.
Yeah.
So,
uh
Yeah, so
it turns out pretty much
you know, a huge percentage of the
computations that we do in deep
learning, remember I was talking you
through auto diff, and it just turns
turns out to be a lot of matrix
operations.
They are very well suited for running on
the GPU. Uh we can we can do those
matrix multiplies in parallel, or at
least all that we can multiply with the
elements in parallel before they we sum
them.
Yeah.
Yeah, so JAX knows which device you're
running on. Um so, if you have a
CUDA installed, and you install the CUDA
version of JAX, then it will
automatically look and and use those
devices by default.
So, I don't even have to I know in
PyTorch you kind of have to define which
device you have. In JAX, you just you
don't even have to do that. They just
uh it just knows which device you have.
Yeah, yeah, you need to install the CUDA
CUDA version. Yeah.
Uh it's very simple to do. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yes. Yeah, so the question is if you
have a sequential program or one that
you know, operates on a single
value, like a scalar value, and then
does a lot of sequential Yeah, so then I
would I would agree with you that uh GPU
is not ideal for that, and it would
likely be slower.
So, you do have to think about the the
types of tasks that you want to put on
the GPU. So, JAX is also JAX. NumPy also
runs very fast on the CPU.
In some cases faster than normal NumPy,
so it may even still be fine to use JAX.
I have an example of that coming up.
Yeah.
Uh I That's a good question. Um I think
so.
So, XLA, which is the back end, which
compiles all the code down onto the GPU,
I think it supports quite uh quite many
different GPUs, not just Nvidia ones.
Um for sure, it supports TPUs, which are
Google's Google's uh
um yeah, accelerator.
Okay.
So,
yeah, I want to make the point I want to
argue the point that a lot of the kind
of scientific software that we use does
indeed use
uh you know, matrix multipliers or like
matrix operations
um or tensor operations in general.
Uh and it's not just our machine
learning workflows, it's like our
traditional scientific workflows, too.
So,
So, this is a finite difference
simulation um
of the wave equation. So, this is a
fairly high-frequency uh large kind of
simulation
uh of of these waves propagating through
an earth model
from some source here.
Um
And this is the code uh to actually run
that simulation. So,
you probably can't see it in detail. It
doesn't matter that you can't read it uh
each line for line.
Uh but, what I've got on the right here
is just a NumPy implementation um
and this is a finite difference scheme.
So, what that involves is just, you
know, starting with a initial wave
field,
and then doing finite differences on the
wave field to to numerically solve the
PDE.
And so, the finite differences do things
like taking that wave field array, and
then uh
uh
subtracting it with itself, but shifted
by one. I mean, you can That's obviously
a big matrix multiplication that we can
do in parallel. That's a kind of
element-wise operation.
Um
uh
uh So, this is kind of what what all
this intermediate stuff is doing inside
this for loop of this finite difference
scheme.
Um
So, I can do the same thing in JAX. I
can Yeah, so there's a lot of
element-wise matrix operations. So, you
could see how this lends itself very
well to running on the GPU. A GPU could
do each of these element computations in
parallel on all of those thousands of
cores.
So,
what we can do is just um
rewrite it in JAX. So, we just import
jax.numpy instead of import numpy.
And in many cases, it it can just be as
simple as that um depending on how
you've written your NumPy code.
Uh
the JAX code can look incredibly
similar, if not the same.
Um
So, you can see how how similar this JAX
version is. Uh we're using again
jax.numpy looks like numpy, so the
padding operations, they have the same
inputs and outputs, for example, all the
other function calls as well.
Um the only thing that we change is at
the bottom here, instead of doing a for
loop to kind of update the wave field
through time, we do
a a lower-level lower-level call, which
is called jax.lax.scan, which which
essentially implements a for loop that
uh allows it allows that for loop to be
compiled and run faster than a kind of a
native Python for loop.
Uh So, this is more of a technical
detail of JAX. It's important to
understand this, but uh
but I can tell you more about that later
if you're if you're interested.
But, what you need to take away from
this slide is it can be just as as
simple as replacing your input statement
import statement to to change your code
on into JAX.
So, once we've done that, we can then
run that wave simulation on the GPU.
And so, here's the run times of the
comparison. So, this is NumPy on the
GPU.
And I've I've tried to fully optimize
this NumPy code, so it uh NumPy
tries to uses
uh kind of vectorized computations. So,
I I tried to remove as many for loops as
possible. This is what makes uh array
computations slow in in Python.
Um so, I I optimized this as much as I
could, and and so this ran on
on again on my MacBook uh with 8 seconds
to do a whole simulation.
Now, I can take my JAX NumPy code and
compile it. Um so, this is an extra
feature that JAX lets us do.
Um and once I've compiled it, this runs
uh 1.5 seconds. So, this is already five
times faster just with a compilation on
top of the of the NumPy code.
Um so, this kind of answers maybe helps
answer your question that it can be
faster on the CPU uh if you do a
compilation on top.
Uh but, the amazing thing is when it
runs on the GPU and it's compiled, uh
it's 123 times faster. So, we're going
from kind of an 8-second simulation down
to a 65-millisecond simulation, which is
kind of impressive, like given how uh
how how high like high-frequency or
fairly complicated this simulation is.
Okay.
So, hopefully I've argued that uh you
know, JAX, but just like other libraries
like PyTorch and TensorFlow,
uh allows you to run these kind of
linear linear algebra computations on
the GPU and really accelerate them
beyond what we can do on the CPU.
Um any questions so far?
Okay.
So, the next thing I want to talk about,
which is the really interesting thing
for me, is is JAX's program
transformation ability.
And so, this idea is what allows JAX to
do things like auto differentiation uh
and auto parallelism, uh parallelize
your computation across many inputs
uh without you having to write any more
code.
And I this is probably the most powerful
thing about JAX. This is why it's so
useful for using it in this kind of
final workflows.
So hands up who knows what a a program
transformation is or a function
transformation?
Okay. So new concept.
So what is a program transformation? So
let me just write
a very simple function here in Python.
Uh this is just a function that takes X,
the value of X, and returns X squared.
So um
a program transformation or in JAX looks
like this.
And this is a program transformation
that
turns that function
into a new function that instead of
computing
the X squared, it computes the the
gradient of this function.
So the gradient of of this function is
two times X.
So
this jax.grad takes in a function as
input. This is not a value or anything
like this. This is a Python a native
Python function.
And it
the object that it returns is another
native Python function.
But when you call that function
gives you the gradient of the original
function. So this is a program
transformation. It takes a program or
generally a function in Python and
returns a new function.
Who's with me?
Yeah, go on.
It's an operate it's an operator. Yeah,
it's an operator. Yeah.
If in a mathematical sense, yeah.
Did you have a question? That's good.
So let me just
enumerate that for you.
We just create a an array with a value
of X in it here.
Uh and if we print the value of we call
this function this new transform
function, we'll print the value of
of the gradient and we get 20. So two
times X.
But what's really nice is we don't we
can then call that we can take that
function and call it with some other
value and we'll get the gradient for
some other value of X.
So how's this different from PyTorch or
or TensorFlow 2.0?
How does PyTorch compute gradients or do
autograd?
Yeah, go on.
Uh
So how would you get the how would you
get the gradient of f of x with PyTorch?
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, so PyTorch doesn't give you this
like function that you can evaluate at
any point in X.
What it does is you define a specific
value of X.
You do a computation on that value.
And then you pull autograd back through
the computational graph to get the
gradient at that value.
So it's a bit it's slightly different.
So each time you'll have to create a new
value of X, do a new computation on X,
and then pull backprop again.
Yeah.
Yes.
Uh
Yes, it is.
It is the same, but uh
we can do we can we get the function
explicitly. So we can carry it around in
our code and we can apply it elsewhere.
Which is maybe more powerful than
PyTorch cuz that's like a function that
we can evaluate.
By the way, JAX I think
PyTorch also has this kind of program
transformation ability now. This is kind
of a the latest stuff they're working on
in PyTorch.
Um
Uh so that's also something to note as
well.
Uh
so how does it actually do this? So
what
this is where
JAX is actually in my opinion like a
technical marvel. How how it actually
does this behind the scenes is very
impressive.
And and and what it does is it actually
takes this native Python function that
we defined.
And it turns it into a
simpler more intermediate language,
which is JAX's own language called JAX
PR. So it's kind of a a lower level
representation of this function.
Um again, I'm not going to go into the
details of this language, but you can
see that it's just rewriting this
function and and turning it into
something that looks a bit more low
level with kind of types defined and
other things like this.
Once it's got that intermediate
representation
then it applies
the transformation directly to this this
intermediate
representation.
And it will produce a new function. And
if you look at the like intermediate
representation of that function, you can
see that that function is
you know, the exact function that
computes the gradient. If you look at
that long enough, you can see it's just
doing kind of two times X.
Um
and giving giving you the gradient.
So yeah, it really is giving you the
function that you evaluate to get to get
the gradient, you know, two two X.
Okay.
So this is what a program transformation
is. It's transforming one program to
another program.
And the way that JAX does it is it
treats the the lines of code here that
you actually wrote as data.
Uh and and and transforms that into a
new function. So this is known as kind
of metaprogramming. It's like programs
that write new programs.
It's not just doing array computation.
It's like taking in actual lines of code
and spitting out new lines of code.
Everyone now understand what a program
transformation is?
Okay.
So this is where JAX gets really
powerful is that once you've got once
you've spit out a new function, again
this is a native Python function. We can
take that function and then apply it
some other separate transform into it.
Uh and do the same process recursively
if we like.
Uh and so this is
the power of JAX is that these program
transformations can be arbitrarily
composed.
So a a simple
uh extra transformation we might do is
take this function that
you know, is just computing two X.
And we just call
jax.grad again to get the function
that computes the gradient of that
function, which is just two.
So
if we call this new function, again we
can query at any point in X,
we'll get we'll get the second order
derivative of the original function.
So this is really really nice.
Um
I would argue a much
clearer or kind of explicit way of
computing gradients and doing autograd.
So this is going to allow us to develop
some very highly sophisticated kind of
workflows using using this idea of
arbitrary composition of function
transformations.
Does this make sense to everyone how
this works? Yeah.
No, it doesn't so it's not it doesn't
use analytic rules or is it
it so we talked about auto
differentiation.
And we talked about vector Jacobian
products.
And I talked you through the algorithm
that
computes
vector Jacobian products.
Where you basically define the forward
forward operation, but for each
primitive operation, you also define the
vector Jacobian product. And then as you
as you you do a forward pass and then a
backward pass
and that will give you the gradient.
And and so this is this is actually
exactly what it's doing here. If you
look at this transformed function, it's
doing the vector Jacobian product
computation.
So it's it's doing like a
a a forward product here and then it's
doing you know, the backprop through the
vector Jacobian products through that.
So that's that's what grad is actually
doing. It's just writing the whole auto
the whole autograd
computation down as a function.
Okay.
So I'm going to do some coding. You can
have a you can follow the link if you
like.
Uh
Yeah, if you if you want to grab it, you
can.
So this is a notebook that you can go
through. It's a very basic introductory
notebook on JAX.
Um
Let me just change my screen.
Um so
I'm just going to show you some of what
we've already covered just in this in
this notebook. So
um
we're just going to import JAX like we
just import any other Python library.
And
again, this is just an example of doing
some very basic array computation in
JAX. And like I said, we just create an
array just like we were doing in NumPy.
And then just do some basic array
multiplication or element-wise operation
here.
Um
the other thing that's happening here is
X is just a
a one by three array here.
So who's heard of broadcasting? Who's
used broadcasting in NumPy?
Yeah, this is where you have like a one
in if you have a dimension size which is
one,
it can kind of
parallelize that across another
computation or broadcast it in general.
So that's what it's actually doing here
when it's creating this this array.
So all of that kind of
clever broadcasting stuff in NumPy is
also in JAX.
So what we're going to do here is we're
just going to do auto differentiation
with JAX just like I showed you. So,
this time I've got tanh. Uh
this is my function that I'm going to
differentiate. So, if I just plot this
for
uh I've got a
vector here of of X values from -5 to 5.
So, this is uh tanh.
So, what I'm going to do is just use uh
the program transformation to transform
this function into its gradient.
So, it's very simple. We just say uh the
f the x.
Again, this is a Python function that's
going to be output is jax.grad
uh of of my function.
And we also want to compute the second
order derivative. So, it's very simple.
All we do is just call jax.grad again.
So,
uh on this new function. And again, we
return an a new a new function which
evaluates the second order derivative.
So, we say the f the uh the two f the x
two function
equals jax.grad
on this guy.
Uh then we run this.
And then what we're doing here is
plotting the result uh across the X
array and and you see JAX is giving us
the gradient and the second order
derivative of tanh.
So, that's just showing you uh you know,
how easy it is uh to do autograd
uh in JAX.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is there like auto differentiation
derivatives? Yeah.
Yeah. So, so I'm passing over the fact
that jax.grad expects um
the output of the function to be scalar.
So, it's the scalar scalar gradient of a
of a function.
Or uh it's the gradient of a scalar
function. The function can have uh
vector inputs. So, it's doing the vector
Jacobian product, but in that case the
vector
that we're multiplying the Jacobian by
is just a simple scalar and it's defined
as one.
Uh
I'm going to talk about right now uh the
lower level other JAX
transformations which can do the VJP in
general and JVP in general. So,
So, this is why I'm having to do a for
loop here because I have to make sure
that the input is scalar the scalar.
Uh
okay.
Sure.
Okay. So,
um
Okay.
Let's check that you can see my screen.
So, uh
I just showed you the gradient which
does the
uh the gradient for a scalar uh
a function that outputs a scalar.
But in general, JAX can do uh vector
Jacobian products and Jacobian vector
products as I was describing in the auto
differentiation lectures.
Um
And uh in fact, all of JAX's auto
differentiations
program transformations are all based on
compositions of the VJP and JVP. They're
just uh specializations or compositions
of these two uh fundamental kind of
program transformations.
Um so, we can do things like get the
gradient of f. We can do we can even get
the Jacobian of f. So, you know, all the
derivatives of of all the partial
derivatives of f with respect to its
inputs.
We can get the Hessian. We can do all
sorts of really interesting things. And
you can go back and have a look at how
these uh the inputs and outputs of these
uh program transformations later.
Um
So,
uh
So, yeah.
Computing the gradient doing auto diff
is just one type of program
transformation. This is actually a much
more general idea than just do it using
it for auto diff.
So, can anyone think of any other like
useful transformations we might want to
make as some if we define some function
in Python, what what might be a
transformation that's useful?
Yeah.
Maybe it's an inverse transformation.
Yeah. Yeah, in that's actually quite a
good idea. Yeah, like invert the
function. So, instead of f of x, it does
x function of f. Yeah.
Uh
so, JAX doesn't have that, but that
would be interesting. Yeah.
Yeah.
Any basis transformation? Yeah. That's a
good idea.
Yeah.
Any others?
Integration. Yeah, very very good. Yeah.
Uh
So,
I'm going to talk about um
some other ones. So,
one is just to vectorize the function.
So, this is a very powerful
transformation in in JAX.
And vectorization
is you can think of it as simply just
parallelizing the function across many
inputs.
But when I mean that, I don't mean
parallelizing it across multiple kind of
devices, multiple CPUs, and multiple
GPUs. I just mean parallelizing it so it
runs uh
in parallel on the single device. So, on
the on the GPU uh in parallel.
So, what what I mean by that is say say
for example, we have this like basic
computation here which is just uh uh a
dot product between two vectors.
Plus some bias. Yeah,
this is a very common operation used in
like any layers of neural networks and
other scientific workflows.
So, say now that I give you many uh
examples of X and I want to times all
those examples by the same weight value.
Mathematically, we can just think of
that as a vector times by a matrix
operation instead of a dot product that
will spit out a vector instead of a
scalar.
Um
And so,
the task here is to take the code the
function that just computes a single for
a single example the dot product and
give you a scalar.
And we might want to vectorize that
function and say, "Okay, we now want to
uh instead of just inputting a single X
to that, X will now have another
dimension which will contain all the
examples all the all the parallel
examples we want to run that computation
over."
Everyone follow so far?
So, if we were just going to write this
in NumPy, we would have to think about,
"Okay, X has changed dimensionality.
We're going to have to change this dot
product with a with a matrix multiply or
make sure that NumPy understands that
there's an extra dimension to X."
But JAX means that you can forget about
that. You can just write your function
for a single example. And then what you
do is you just call jax.vmap. So, this
is vectorized map.
Again, it's another function
transformation. It it uh my function is
input uh any arbitrary Python function.
Um
And you tell it
of the three inputs that it have,
which inputs you want to parallelize
across. And and more specifically, which
dimension of that input we're going to
we're going to denote as having all
these parallel inputs all these these
examples uh
in it.
So, what this function f_batch is going
to say is it's it's going to again, it's
going to take
W as input. It's going to take B as
input. But then it's going to take X
with an extra dimension added on the
first dimension that contains all the
examples that we're going to run in
parallel uh
of X.
So, now if we call if we create X here
with a you know, an extra dimension with
all these examples uh of these vectors
that we want to compute.
And we print the output of f_batch, you
can see that it's now giving us a a
vector as output instead of a scalar.
So, it's doing all these uh in parallel.
Yeah.
Is
it only in sort of vmap vectorized JAX
NumPy functions? So, like yeah, if-else
statements and there you have to rewrite
it like
Uh
vmap can can handle if-else statements.
Um
So, that there there's some
uh
subtleties.
But so, which I don't have time to talk
about, but there are there's uh one of
the limitations of JAX is
uh that the shape that the shapes of the
output shouldn't depend on the values of
the input.
So, what I'm saying is the shape should
be known statically before you input
them to the
uh given the shapes of the inputs of the
function. If you can if you can do that
and make sure that it's a static
computation, then you can use kind of
conditional statements and still
vectorize those those statements.
Yeah.
Um
I think that's true, but uh it's can be
it depends on the program
transformation. That's definitely true
for compilation. I I think that's true
for vectorization, but I'd have to
actually check properly.
Um
So, if you look at the kind of again, if
we look at the intermediate
representation, this is again to to
transform this function, JAX will take
this intermediate representation and
then treat it as input data as input and
spit out a new a new function
which is the vectorized form out.
And if you go into this function and
actually look what it's uh doing, it's
uh inside here it's got uh
uh like a a dot product. Uh this
dot_general here
uh in the original function which is uh
what numpy.dot is doing. But what's
interesting is that when we vmap'd it,
it's realized that we can still do this
as a dot product. This is now instead of
a
vector dot product, this is now a matrix
kind of product instead. And this
generalized dot product can handle that.
So, what's cool is that it's not using
like a for loop. Like the The way of
vectorizing this function would just be
to say for I in range N, call this
function with each input each new X as
input.
It's realized that we don't need to we
don't need to do that. We can actually
just write it as a as a matrix product.
And this is what when we run that matrix
product on the CPU, it will then use the
cores in parallel to do the computation.
So this this is
this vectorized function is much faster
than just doing like a a native Python
for loop to to call the function
repeatedly.
Uh does that make sense?
Okay.
So
uh
let's go back um
and look at that. So
uh oh, I do have a couple more examples
about auto diff. So
uh
This for example, this is the let's just
go back to this auto diff example. So
this is doing the tanh function.
Uh computing tanh.
So we can do jax.jacobian. This will
give us the Jacobian of that function.
Again, this is a function that we call
with a value of X and it will spit out
the Jacobian.
So the Jacobian is a matrix. It's all
the partial derivatives of of F with
respect to X.
And now X here is a an array that we're
inputting. So it's a X in the range
minus five to five.
And what it spits out is an array that
is diagonal. Like a Jacobian is
diagonal. So can anyone tell me why this
this Jacobian is diagonal?
In this case.
For a function that takes in X and spits
out tanh X.
Yeah.
So what when when you call when you call
this function with a vector
it outputs a vector.
So Jax sees that as like a a vector
valued function that has a vector input.
So the Jacobian of that in general would
be a matrix.
But the important thing is that the each
uh output of that function only depends
on the the
the same element in the input.
So you know
F1 only depends on X1, F2 only depends
on X2.
So there's no the gradients of all the
cross derivatives of all the cross
partial derivatives are just zero
because it's a it's it's an element wise
operation.
So yeah, the Jacobian in this case is is
diagonal. So yeah.
And we can also do
uh you know, vector Jacobian products.
So
now X is an array.
Uh
So we do a vector Jacobian product. We
and we define the vector as a uh an
array of ones.
And this will just give us the give us
the gradient uh
element wise gradient.
Uh and we do the same thing with a
forward forward mode auto diff instead.
Uh
and again, that will give us the the
gradient the same gradient. So you can
have a go you can look through this
again in your own time and just convince
yourself what's happening
mathematically.
Okay.
So that's uh talking about
vectorization. So let's
let's uh
let's vectorize this function. So now
we're going to uh vectorize not just
this kind of
simple uh dot product.
Or actually this is a this is now a
matrix vector multiply. We're we're
assuming this is like a layer of a of a
fully connected network. So we have a
weight matrix. We have
a single example. X is a vector.
We're going to add a bias vector and
then we're going to pass it through an
activation function.
So we can call vmap on on this entire
function
uh and allow it uh or vectorize it or
parallelize it across many examples of
X.
Um
So this is just the if I just call the
function with with some random kind of
weight matrix, 10 by three weight matrix
and a an X vector that has three
elements
then yeah, X is the input size of X is
just three a vector with three elements.
The output of the function is a vector
with 10 elements. So this would be the
hidden state after the after the layer.
But say that I have many examples of X
instead. So maybe I've got a thousand
examples like a batch of of training
examples that I'll be feeding to the
network.
So what we do to vectorize this function
is we just do
uh
we
uh just call jax.vmap on this top thing.
Um
So we grab the function
and we say which axes
uh and which arguments we want to
parallelize across.
So if we don't want to parallelize
across any of the arguments, then we'll
just put a none. So just saying that
we're not going to parallelize.
For the first two arguments and then for
the last one
we're just going to say the examples are
in the first dimension of the of the
input.
And then again, when we when we run this
uh function forwards with an with a
batched example, then we get a batch
batch of outputs.
So you can see how this is can become
very powerful when we have very
complicated functions. We can vectorize
the whole function across all the NumPy
operations that we have in our function.
Um
Okay.
So
uh
let me swap again.
Okay. So next uh next type of program
transformation is a is a compilation.
So
I'm not going to go into details about
how Jax is doing compilation. I'll give
maybe one example. But at a very high
level, you can just think of this as
taking my original Python code and just
rewriting it
using this lower level representation
and also XLA, this accelerated linear
algebra compiler
to make it run faster on the specific
device that you're using.
Um
and
so this is an example of how
we might make this code a bit faster.
So this is a function that just computes
X plus X squared plus X cubed.
And uh
the way that this function might run uh
on the GPU if you just call it this way
in Jax
is there are separate kind of underlying
CUDA kernels.
Uh these are kind of like
uh
low level pieces of code that are
defined to run like small operations
very fast.
So there might be a a CUDA kernel that
is defined for like a simple matrix
multiply or an element wise
multiplication like an X squared.
There might be another kernel which is a
different implementation that runs X
cubed. And then there might be a final
kernel that is called to to sum all
these these things together.
And if if the code uses separate
kernels, then usually what happens is
that uh each kernel runs independently
as like an independent thread or kind of
job on this on the on the GPU.
Uh it reads from the kind of global
memory of the GPU for its inputs and
then saves those outputs of that
individual kernel back to the memory.
Back to the global memory of the GPU. So
this is the kind of shared memory across
all the cores.
So what takes time in in in in this
whole uh operation is to is the reading
and writing to the global memory. This
this is the kind of bottleneck of these
of these computations.
What you would
when you call
Jax compilation, it realizes that uh
these three kernels can actually be
fused into a single kernel. So kind of
writes a kind of custom kernel or a
fused kernel
that doesn't have to do all these kind
of reads and writes to the memory. It
just it knows that I can just do one
read to the memory of X. I can do all
these X computations and sum them
together without having to save and
rewrite to the memory. So kind of
minimizes these these uh communication
steps and gives you a fused kernel when
you when you compile the code.
So this is just one example of how uh
this again, this is a function
transformation. It takes your function
and gives you a compiled version of that
function that runs very fast.
This is just one example uh of how Jax
optimizes the code. Uh Jax does many
other very sophisticated optimizations
with with XLA that I'm not going to talk
about.
Um
Long story short, once you've jitted
your code uh and you've compiled it, it
often runs much much faster. So for
example
when we fuse these operations together,
we can just get a speed up of eight
times already. So you know, by reducing
the
uh bottleneck of
uh of read and write to the global
memory.
Um
So yeah, behind the scenes this is using
uh XLA, accelerated linear algebra both
for the CPU and GPU and I think it works
for other
specialized devices, too.
Like TPUs and and other other devices.
Um but there is a there is a cost here
and the cost is that it takes time to
compile the function. Uh it depends on
the function, but sometimes this can
take seconds or more.
Uh
and this is kind of an up up front cost
is to do that compilation. So typically
you're only kind kind of compile
functions that you know you're going to
run hundreds of times so that that
upfront cost doesn't uh is kind of
amortized or is is not important.
So if you imagine like training a deep
neural network
one function that we call thousands of
times is the function that does the
update of the network's weights. So does
the gradient descent step.
So when we use Jax compilation in deep
learning, usually we compile the the
update step and that takes that's
expensive for the first update, but then
for the next million updates, it's very
fast.
Any questions on this?
Okay.
So um I'll just go back to the
JIT compilation and then we'll take a
break. Um
So yeah, here's an example of exactly
that function. Just to prove to you that
if I compile that function and then I I
time time how long it takes to run that
function
uh for a fairly large array. This is
running on my CPU, by the way, so I'm
not even on a GPU, but the compilation
still makes the CPU run uh much faster,
so
it's going to take
uh
this is about an eight times speed up
like I was showing in the in the slides.
And
when I'm calling the jit function rather
than the the original function.
Um
Okay, so I'm going to describe
I think we'll take a break and then I'll
and then I'll describe a the final
example. We're going to put all these
ideas together to do some linear
regression. So
Yep.
Okay, so let's carry on. We're going to
put this all together, all these
concepts that we've learned about
program transformations and do uh linear
regression.
And you're going to see that this pass
is going to uh use all of these
transformations. So we're going to use
the vec vmap, we're going to use uh jit
compilation, we're going to use the
graph transformation all together and
compose them together to solve this.
Uh so here's our here's our training
data. We just want to fit a straight
line to this data. That's that's what
we're going to do in one in one
dimension.
Um
So
first of all, I'm just going to define a
function that gives us our initial guess
of what our weight and our bias value
is. This is just the the gradient and
the intercept of the line. They're both
scalar values.
So we're going to use gradient descent
to solve linear regression. Obviously,
we can do it uh at more analytically,
but this is just for the purpose of
demonstration.
Uh so then this is our forward model. Uh
like we would do in PyTorch, we would
define like a forward
uh function.
So we're just going to grab our uh
weight bias value. We're going to do the
matrix multiply of with with X,
which is uh simply just a dot product uh
or in fact, it's just a single scalar
times by single scalar in this in this
case.
Uh plus plus a bias.
And then I've got uh I'm going to vmap
my forward batch. So this is written for
a a single example, a single value of X,
a scalar value in this case cuz it's a
1D line.
Uh and we're going to vmap it so that uh
it can take in all of these all of these
examples of X that we have. I don't uh
we have 100 different uh training points
here.
Then we're going to define a a loss
function which takes the batch of X
values, the labels of Y, so the X and Y
uh coordinates that we have in training
data.
It's going to call this vmap version of
the forward function, so so compute the
prediction for all of the training
points.
And then our loss function is just uh
the prediction of the
uh of the Y value, uh
the mean squared error uh between the
labels and the prediction.
Everyone follow me so far?
Right.
Then we're going to call this gradient
uh transformation. So value and grad is
just a
uh
is a another program transformation that
just spits out the gradient and also the
value of the function at the same time.
So it gives us both values.
Um
And we're going to the we're going to
differentiate loss with respect to the
first argument. So uh this is going to
give us dL by d theta. So this is the
gradient of the loss with respect to the
the weights of the of the model.
So with respect to W and B here.
So then the final thing we need to do is
do a a gradient descent step. We need to
define
define uh a function that we're going to
call many many times in a for loop to do
gradient descent on on the weights.
So that's what I'm going to write.
Um
So
to
to do the step, we just need to compute
the gradient and then we need to update
the weights based on that gradient. So
how do I compute the gradient?
Yeah.
So we we did that already. We've got
we've got a function here, grad. This is
a a function. This is a program
transformation.
It takes loss and gives me the gradient
of the loss.
So all we need to do is just call that
function. So we just say uh
dL d theta
equals grad.
And then we pass all the arguments of
the of the original function. So we pass
all these guys
uh to that.
So like I said, this transformation not
only gives you the gradient, but also
just gives you the value of the loss. So
we just uh we get both when when we call
that function.
And so now we need to update theta based
on the gradient of theta. So
we say theta
equals So theta here is actually a
tuple, it's a Python tuple,
uh which just contains the weight and
the bias values.
So I need to go into that tuple and
update the weight. So so the upper here,
this dL by d theta is also a tuple,
which has the gradient of both of those
quantities in it.
So I need to go into that tuple and
update the tuple. So JAX has like a a
handy kind of utility function which is
called jax.tree_map.
So what this does is take any kind of
Python tree. So a tree would be like a
nested structure like a a dictionary or
a dictionary with lists in or that has
some sort of leaves at the bottom.
So this tuple is is also a Python uh a
pytree, which JAX
just applies uh uh some function to to
each of the leaves of that tree. So
so the function that we want to do is
just the gradient descent step. So we
just we specify what this the function
is.
Um so the function's going to take the
theta value and the gradient like this
and it's going to say
uh
we're going to do it take a gradient
descent step by times in the gradient by
a by a small value.
And then we're going to up map this
function to uh
uh the the theta tree and the gradient
tree like this.
So can you see how
what we're just going through here is
we're just going through these tuples
and updating the gradients of each of
the elements of the tuple. That's that's
what we're doing.
And then uh
we just need to return
uh
the theta and the loss value like this.
So this is performing one gradient
descent step and then and then what we
have here is just a for loop which is
going to call uh that that step uh
function many many times. Before we call
it, we're actually going to use jit to
compile this function. So this is what I
was saying, we we typically when we're
training training models, we we compile
the highest highest level function we
can, which in this case is the function
that does the gradient descent step.
Uh
Any questions on this before I before I
run it?
Okay.
So if you run it and it does it straight
away.
It's uh
this is why jit is so powerful. It just
runs so quickly on these like small
small operations. So we've we've I just
ran 1,000 gradient descent steps and it
did it basically instantly on my on my
CPU.
Um and we fit we fit the line.
Okay.
Uh
So let's go back to the slides.
Okay.
So I talked about uh
the kind of fundamental
uh
features of JAX, the accelerated array
computation and the program
transformation
uh in a very general way.
Um
and these things
can help us do big machine learning
tasks, but there's also a lot of effort
using JAX to for scientific machine
learning tasks.
So
uh doing exactly the types of techniques
that we've been studying in this course,
combining machine learning very tightly
with our scientific computing algorithms
that we have already.
And uh these are just some of the
libraries that have been built on top of
JAX that help us do these kind of sci-ML
kind of uh type tasks.
So there's uh
optimization libraries for doing, you
know, gradient descent and higher order
kind of optimization methods. Optax, JAX
opt, Optimistics. There are many many uh
libraries out there.
There are also other libraries that
allow you to train neural networks and
uh define neural network architectures.
So
JAX is maybe a bit different to PyTorch
in the sense that JAX doesn't have like
a a built-in module that does neural
networks. You you you use you have to
use one of these kind of external
libraries to do that.
There's uh other Yeah, go on.
JAX
Yeah.
So the question is, can you combine
PyTorch and JAX together? Um
I think it would be difficult because of
the way they do autograd very
fundamentally different. Where PyTorch
has defined its own version of an array
or a a PyTorch tensor, which has this
gradient attribute.
So to convert that to a JAX array would
be probably be quite difficult
uh
inside of some hybrid autograd code.
But what you could do
if
if there's like some preprocessing step
or if there's like some other thing that
doesn't need PyTorch gradients, it's
just like a brute force computation, you
could offload that to a jit compiled JAX
code that spits out an array that then
PyTorch can just convert into a PyTorch
tensor.
Uh
so
yeah, there's maybe maybe ways, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know actually if there's a
like a library that converts between uh
libraries.
Uh
Yeah, I'm not sure.
Yeah, yeah. I'm I'm not not sure. Maybe,
but
Uh so, these libraries are certainly not
as developed as PyTorch. So, so this
goes back to my your question before my
advice about should I use PyTorch or
should I use JAX? I think both libraries
are brilliant. Uh just to learn both
libraries is very useful for you to kind
of develop.
But, yeah, in general I would use
PyTorch to do kind of standard deep
learning tasks where I want to train
like a standard neural network, but I
would use JAX if I want to do something
more complicated where I want like more
complex derivatives, if I want to
combine forward mode with also uh
reverse mode auto diff, if I want to do
Hessians, if I want to do parallelism
across multiple devices, etc. And and
also if I want to compose all this
stuff.
Um
Okay. So, scientific computing. So,
there are there are also libraries that
can do, you know, the types of stuff
that we need to do in scientific
computing. So, things like matrix solves
uh or linear algebra computations.
Diffrax is an amazing library that uh
allows you to train neural differential
equations. So, to solve ODEs and also
SDEs.
Uh
and also define learnable components of
those and and backprop through them just
like we were talking about in the neural
differential equation lectures.
There's JAX.SciPy which does uh tries to
it's not a full set of uh NumPy
uh of the original SciPy library, but it
has some of the some of the
functionality.
Um and then there are a lot of amazing
SciML libraries. Some of you might have
been talking about these before. So, for
example, uh JAX MD is a a highly
performant library from from molecular
dynamics.
Uh Brax again is this rigid body
simulation in JAX. NumPyro is a
probabilistic programming language. So,
you know, doing like Bayesian inference
uh using JAX. Super interesting.
JAX CFD, computational fluid dynamics uh
on GPUs. Pretty cool.
DeepXDE uh is a PINs library or or a
physics-informed machine learning
library. So,
there's a lot of really cool stuff
happening in this SciML ecosystem.
So, the final example that I want to end
on um
is to show you an example of using
optimization in JAX and using the Optax
library. So, this is uh
a library that's often used for for
gradient descent in JAX.
And I just want to show you how it easy
it is to solve a scientific problem. I'm
not doing any machine learning here. I'm
just trying to solve the inverse problem
for this wave equation example.
So, what's the inverse problem? It's to
say, if I give you a uh an example of
what the wave field is at some time,
can I guess what the the line velocity
model is that that
uh that uh
earthquake or or seismic wave propagated
through?
Um and so, we can frame that as an
optimization problem. We can start with
some guess of what the velocity model is
and we would just maybe start with a
smooth version of what we what we might
think it is.
And then we can just run the forward
simulator, you know, call the finite
difference simulator to to predict what
the the estimated wave field is. And
then have a loss function which matches
the estimated wave field to the true
wave field.
Use JAX's autograd to get the gradient
of that loss function with respect to
the velocity model and then update that
velocity model using gradient descent.
So, it's like a a standard
optimization algorithm for this like
inverse problem.
And what's nice, I already showed you
the code for doing the forward
simulation. It was like maybe 50 lines
of code and basic NumPy code.
This is all that I need to add to be
able to solve the inverse problem. I
just define the the loss function which
takes in my guess of the velocity and uh
the true wave field measurements there.
Right, calls the forward function. So,
this calls that finite difference solver
to get the estimated wave field. And
then we just match the estimated wave
field to the true wave field.
And this is where JAX really kicks in is
we can then call JAX.grad on on our on
our loss to give us our gradient
function.
Uh
and uh we just define an optimizer in in
in Optax, uh the Adam optimizer. So,
again, we can use kind of modern deep
learning optimizers to to solve this
inverse problem.
Uh and then update the gradients. Uh we
can also compile this. I haven't written
JAX compilation, but we can jit compile
the update function just like we did
before.
And uh
yeah, just with like maybe 10 extra
lines of code, we can solve solve this
inverse problem. So, super powerful.
Uh
To have written this by hand, to write
the gradients out by hand would would
have taken a lot more effort to to do.
And and this is running
very performant in a very performant
way, very very quickly. Remember, each
forward simulation here is only taking
65 milliseconds in my on the GPU.
Okay.
Anyone know why uh the estimated
velocity is only fills in the the
circle?
Go on.
That's great.
Yeah.
Yeah, because the true the true wave
field there only propagates to that back
point here. Uh
And so, there's no information. The the
waves haven't traveled through this part
of velocity, so we could never
understand what the velocity is in this
part. Yeah, it's just
problem-specific behavior.
Okay.
So, that's my high-level uh
pitch for JAX. Um there are other great
options. So, another option people
compare to is Julia. This is Julia is a
whole other programming language, but
has kind of other functionality which is
similar to JAX. I'm just more familiar
with JAX, but I encourage you to explore
different languages and different
options for your for your for your tasks
that you you want to solve.
Um but yeah, JAX is a accelerated array
computation and uh program
transformation and auto diff,
vectorization, compilation can all be
thought of as program transformations
and and are available available to use
in JAX.
And JAX really does enable this kind of
high-performance large-scale SciML. So,
that's the end of this lecture. Any any
questions before I'm going to start the
next one uh now.